Your customers used to search for local business information in a phone book.
Now, they search for it in a phone.
People thumb their way to Google Search and Maps to find hours,...
...phone numbers, menus and more.
And when you claim your listing,...
...you can make sure you're showing up exactly the way you'd like.
With Google My Business, you can update your info anytime no matter where you are,...
...so your customers always know how to reach you.
Bet you've got a lot going on, right?
This free tool takes about 10 minutes.
All you need to do is let us know you're you.
Then, you're on your way to showing up across the web and you're back to business.
If you wanna jazz it up a bit, you can add a description,...
...post a photo of today's special and even add a 360-degree tour of your space.
We know making your customers happy is what you work for,...
...so you can get savvy about the people searching for you.
Are they coming from your neighborhood?
Did they click the link on that blog post your nephew wrote?
Plus, you can respond to people's reviews.